a strong weather system is threatening
outdoor New Year's Eve plans from coast
to coast a large portion of the country
will ring in 2023 with heavy rain
powerful winds and in parts of the West
snow here in New York many are keeping
an eye on the weather for one of the
biggest New Year's Eve celebrations of
all for the first time since 2019 there
will be no covered restrictions on the
festivities in Times Square that means
no masks no vaccine requirements and no
testing meteorologist Reynolds wolf from
our partners at the weather channel has
the latest Reynolds good morning
well Happy New Year's Eve everyone let's
take a look at the forecast what you can
expect as we ring in the New Year and as
we start 2023 we have a lot to share
with you so first off let's show you
that for a bunch of the Eastern Seaboard
you're going out to celebrate to bring
in the New Year you're probably going to
need some rain gear along Parts the 95
Corridor out to the West we do have an
abundance of cooler air and check out
the snow it has been quite the snow
season so far and it looks like in terms
of the snow it's only going to get
better as we get into tomorrow however
if you keep an eye on that system out to
the West that is going to be a
troublemaker as we move forward in time
in fact as you get into Monday and
Tuesday there will be more snow but also
a severe weather component very similar
to what we saw just a few weeks ago we
also have a flood threat so again quite
a bit of tangle with as we make our way
into early next week now in terms of the
snowfall that's going to be pretty
substantial but the severe weather
aspect yes take a look at Monday and
into Tuesday so covering very similar
territory back into the Architects
through portions of Texas look at that
even Oklahoma Arkansas and Louisiana but
then the focus from Monday to Tuesday
day migrates a bit more towards the east
so everyone I'll tell you what keep your
heads up meanwhile back in ski country
more the same some locations up to a
foot maybe two feet perhaps even more
now for full coverage of next week's
storms you can watch the Weather Channel
on cable or live on your favorite TV
steam streaming devices Charlie folks
are going to want to stay weather aware
back to you Reynolds thanks so much and
a Happy New Year to you